If you want to see how the father could have
survived while still saving his kids, stick
around to the end of this video.
So I checked out A Quiet Place again and noticed
some new Things You Missed that I wanted to
share with whoever is out there and still
alive and has a pair of headphones. But first
I wanted to address something from the last
video, which you should go here and watch
before watching this video. I got soooo many
comments saying that the red lights were not
meant to hurt the creatures, they were just
a sign to be on red alert, because of aliens
in the area or because the baby was being
born.
I totally agree. That is the purpose of the
red lights, and I didn't mean for it to come
off in any other way. What I was saying was
that when the wife turns on the red lights,
there is an unmistakable high pitched sound
emmited from them. Go back and watch that
scene and you'll see what I mean. I don't
know if that is an intended side effect of
having the red lights on or if it was just
a happy accident, but it does seem to throw
the monsters off a little bit by providing
the family with a long string of continuous
sound.
Just as the river offered protection from
small noises, this, on an even quieter level,
may have afforded them a little leeway needed
to move around the house. But the other then
the volume, another difference between the
river and the sting of red lights, is that
the sound coming from the lights is a much
higher frequency, and as we saw from the hearing
aid, an extremely high frequency sound can
hurt the monsters and make them vulnerable.
So when I talked about the opening shot of
the movie, with the traffic lights taken down,
I was just saying that could be a clue for
the audience, as to what the weakness might
be. When watching the movie again, I noticed
perhaps when more evidence towards this. After
the baby is born, when the father comes up
from the bunker to find the two older kids,
the string lights are now ripped from the
ceiling and on the floor. The aliens didn't
really attack anything else in the house,
other than the water pipe, which may have
been inadvertent, like the pipe just happened
to intersect with where the lights were set
up.
But like I said the main purpose of those
lights was a visual cue for everyone to be
on high alert, because obviously blasting
a siren or something wouldn't work in their
favor.
There was one other thing in the last video
that I got more evidence for the second time
around, which was my theory that the creatures
are in fact aliens. Remember, last time we
had this shot that was used in a trailer but
not the movie. This time I noticed a couple
more headlines posted up in the father's basement
lab. The first read "meteorite hits Mexico"
which gives us a clue about where and how
the epidemic started. If you were wondering
where A Quiet Place takes place, there's a
newspaper stand in town that says Little Falls,
NY. So the family we see in the movie had
some time to prepare before the aliens made
their way across North America to get to them.
There was another headline I caught that was
way in the background, and partially cut off
screen. I saw the letters A L I E... So I'm
assuming that says Aliens, and I think we've
got enough to confirm now that these creatures
are extra terrestrials. My question is, what
did the father do before the apocalypse, that
left him so well prepared? I think it's likely
he was some kind of telecommunications expert,
because of all the equipment he has, but he
also sets up his own video surveillance, and
has a printed list of every country. Keep
in mind, he would have had to have that printed
before the invasion started, because printers
are loud.
So what do you think he did before the takeover?
And why didn't he want his daughter going
into the basement? Leave your ideas in the
comments.
One thing you may or may not have noticed
early on that certainly went past me was the
seriousness of the opening scene. The family
goes to a drug store to get pills for the
older son, who is sick. It's pretty scary
to think that even a simple cough could be
deadly in this world because of the noise.
Minor congestion could lead to snoring, which
could also be dangerous. That why the father
has medical supplies written on his whiteboard,
staying healthy becomes extremely important.
I'm guessing they go into town for supplies
fairly often, because the father actually
lays down a sand path all the way down into
town to quiet their footsteps.
There were a couple of other things I noticed
that they did to keep things quiet, like painting
the floorboards that don't creek a slightly
different color.
Someone else in the comments talked about
the reason that the hearing aid bugs out around
the aliens. I had previously said it could
be because of a feedback loop, but this person
suggested that the aliens might give off some
kind of electromagnetic waves that mess with
electronics. There seems to be even more evidence
for this. When the wife goes into labor, a
lightbulb above the bath flickers as the alien
comes up the stairs. We see the same thing
happen in the basement to a smaller lamp,
and when the monster goes down near the surveillance
screens, they all turn to static. After the
creature is killed, they return to normal.
I did pick up something very interesting in
the early going about the younger son. It
almost seems like he doesn't have the will
to live quietly. Kids are always loud an obnoxious,
and maybe they need to get that energy out
by making noise. He draws a rocket ship on
the floor of the drug store and tells his
sister "that's how we get away." Then he intentionally
put in the batteries and turns on the rocket
on the bridge. So he essentially uses the
rocket to get away from this life that he
hates. That's a dark way of looking at it,
but after seeing it again, it does look to
be intentional. I thought it was strange that
they let the kid trail behind the pack like
that. I mean if he were to have wandered off,
they would likely never find him. They wouldn't
be able to call out how name when they went
searching for him, which would make it pretty
much impossible. I would have kept the kid
in front. And towards the end of the movie,
there was something I would have done differently
as well. The dad's last action to save his
kids was to yell out and distract the alien
trying to get into the car that the kids are
hiding in. Moments before, he grabs an axe
from the toolshed and tries to fight the creature
off, which doesn't work. I think all he had
to do was throw that axe back into the toolshed
and aim to knock over some stuff in there.
That should have afforded them some time to
flee.
The other thing I thought about was the fact
that the baby is born on Day 473, and comes
about 2 weeks early. That means the baby must
have been concieved around day 259, almost
a year into the invasion. So what does that
mean? Aside from probably some really boring
quiet sex, it means they intentionally brought
a child into this world, most likely to try
to do whatever they could to prevent mankind
from dying out.
There may actually be some religious symbolism
to match the themes of perpetuating man. The
first being that the baby is mentioned to
be male. When the nursery is flooded, the
baby seems to be floating in that wood box.
The image was reminiscent of baby Moses being
sent down the river in a wood basket to survive
the Israelites.
I also found the old couple scene to be significant.
The father takes his son to the river with
him to show him how to survive on his own.
Then they come across the old couple. The
woman is dead and the man gives himself up.
This is a symbolic passing of the torch from
old to new. The boy experiences a rite of
passage, and at the end of the movie, he'll
be expected to rise up and become the man
of the household.
And I'm going to refer to the newspapers one
more time for another religious connotation.
More then one publication refers to the aliens
as "angels of death" or "dark angels of destruction"
which could go back to the idea of the new
baby representing Moses and the angel of death
passing over him.
If you're interested in that kind of stuff,
go check out my Things You Missed on mother!
where I go much more in depth about the religious
symbolism from Aronofsky's latest flick. Just
make sure you stay quiet, stay safe and stay
up to date on my new videos by subscribing
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I'll see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.